-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
You guys, New York City
is buzzing tonight because
last night in Toronto,
Yankees superstar Aaron Judge
hit his 61st home run
of the season,
tying Roger Maris'
American League record.
Yep, Aaron Judge
did the impossible.
He made non-Yankee fans
root for the Yankees.
It was a special moment.
New Yorkers haven't
cheered like this since
Bill de Blasio left office.
It was really amazing.
Fans waited 61 years for
this to happen.
That's right -- six decades of
waiting for one exciting moment.
That sums up baseball
pretty well.
It was a historic night
for Aaron Judge,
and you could tell the announcer
was pretty excited,
but I'm not sure about his
home-run call.
Take a listen to this.
-Swung on
and drilled deep left field.
It is gone!
He's done it! Move over, 69!
The new hot thing to do
in the bedroom is 61!
Its bom to the bom-bom.
He's rounding the bases
like a senior on prom night!
He's about to hear something
I never heard from my dad,
which is,
"I'm proud of you, Son."
Man, oh, man,
that ball left faster
than my wife with the pool boy.
Oh, baby!
-He had weeks to practice that.
Wasn't even appropriate,
I thought.
-Very emotional for him.
-Yeah.
I thought -- Of course, a lot of
people went from the game
hoping to catch
the home-run ball.
You go the game, "Oh, my gosh.
If I catch this..."
It was worth a
quarter of a million dollars
if you caught the ball.
And one guy came pretty close.
Here he is. Look at this.
Look at --
Less than 1 foot away.
Yeah. Yeah. Oh, my gosh.
And then every guy
who showed up to the game with
a fishing net was like,
"Well, who's laughing now?"
And get this -- the guy --
This is real.
The guy who almost caught
the ball was a Toronto Blue Jays
fan named -- and this is real --
Frankie Lasagna.
-What?
-Yeah.
-Frankie Lasagna?
-Frankie Lasagna
is that fan right there, yeah.
Frankie Lasagna -- it sounds
like a name you get from
the Olive Garden
Witness Protection Program.
Frankie Lasagna sounds like
the name Robert De Niro
checks into hotels
to avoid paparazzi.
He's like...
-Hey!
-Frankie Lasagna sounds like
the name of Trump's next lawyer.
He's like, "Frankie Lasagna
is the greatest."
Speaking of Trump,
it was just revealed
that during the
FBI search of Mar-a-Lago,
they seized 200,000 pages
of documents
from the former president.
200,000 pages.
He's like a grandpa
who prints every e-mail.
He's like...
Yeah, if the FBI delayed
their search another day,
the TV show "Hoarders"
would have beat them to it.
Some more news.
I read the Nord Stream
pipelines,
which funneled
gas from Russia to Europe,
has started leaking
due to underwater explosions.
And the U.S. and Europe think
that Russia is responsible.
-Ooh!
-Yeah, a leaky pipeline.
Today, President Biden was like,
"Oh, I have a
great urologist for that."
Hey, guys, listen to this.
A new poll shows that
more Democrats
are now saying they want Biden
to run for re-election,
and if he doesn't,
Vice President Harris
is their top choice.
That poll was conducted
among two people --
Joe Biden and Kamala Harris.
Meanwhile,
I saw that Bernie Sanders
is leaving the door open
for another presidential run
in 2024.
He'll be 83 years old.
When other members of
the House heard about this,
they had some thoughts.
For example, first up,
Congressman Ken Buck said...
Next up,
Congressman Jim Banks said...
And Congressman
Tom Cotton said...
And Congressman Colin Allred
said...
And Congressman Virginia Foxx
And Congressman Dusty Johnson
said...
"My full name."
-His full name.
♪♪
Oy!
-And, finally,
Senator Roy Blunt said...
There you go.
A lot of opinions there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Did you guys see this?
The other night
at her concert in D.C.,
Lizzo played
President James Madison's
never-used crystal flute.
Yeah. Lizzo said, "I just --"
This is real.
She said, "I just twerked and
played James Madison's
crystal flute from the 1800s.
It's pretty cool."
Well, not many people know this,
but here in the NBC archives,
we actually have
Calvin Coolidge's saxophone.
-Oh!
-This is real. Check this out.
We brought it out
of the archives. That's cool.
I mean, I could play it,
but I just don't know.
I mean, I've never --
I don't think I should.
-Oh, come on.
-No, I mean,
it's the original...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Calvin Coolidge.
This is kind of a --
I don't know if I
even remember how to do it.
[ Saxophone plays ]
-Wow!
[ "Careless Whisper" playing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guys --
-Little story there.
-What's that?
-Little story there. Wow.
-Oh, I don't know
what you're talking about.
-Oh, no. Never mind.
-Well, guys,
there's a lot of buzz around
the new horror movie "Smile."
Did you hear about this movie?
Everybody -- This is going to be
the big movie this weekend.
It's expected to be
such a big hit,
they're already planning on
making a franchise out of it.
Yeah, take a look at
the trailer I just saw.
-This Friday, don't miss
the premiere of "Smile,"
and then be sure to catch all
the heart-stopping sequels...
-Wow. Very interesting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, some business news.
I saw that Hefty
just released new
pumpkin-spice-scented
trash bags.
Right now,
all the raccoons are like,
"I know it's basic,
but I still love it, okay?
Can I just say?"
Well, this is interesting.
According to new research,
the pandemic may have changed
people's personalities forever.
I'm not sure I've noticed anyone
acting differently.
I mean, what about you, Higgins?
-Wouldn't know about that, Jack.
[ Jazz music playing ]
I've always been the same.
Take it from Baccarat Steve.
All Baccarat Steve
has ever cared about is
the click, click, clickedy-clack
of the roulette wheel,
seeing those triple cherries
come up on
my favorite slot machine,
and shoplifting crab legs from
Circus Circus buffet.
Mwah! Come on! Lucky 4s.
-Quest, have you noticed Higgins
has been acting differently?
-[ Chuckles ]
[ Rock music playing ]
I don't pay mind
to anybody but me,
my leather jacket, and my Hog.
[ Chuckles ]
She's a '78 Harley Shovelhead,
and there's nothing more
than I love in life
than a little whipping her down
the South Dakota prairie,
hitting 80 miles per hour
while the old lady
sits behind and feeds me
meatballs from Olive Garden.
-James, do you think
people's personalities
changed because of the pandemic?
-You know me, Jimmy.
I've always been the same,
a fan of all things
science fic--
[ Laughter ]
Science fiction
and geek culture.
I'm the biggest fan
of "House of the Dragon"
this side of Westeros, LOL.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I've even learned
the language spoken
by the elves on the show,
High Valyrian.
Check this out.
[ Clears throat ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-What?
-I had no idea.
-Okay. Thank you.
-Yeah.
-Thank you, James.
-Wow, I guess.
-I don't know.
-Wow, man.
-That's odd.
-Wow.
Finally...
[ Laughter ]
...a new survey
found that over a quarter --
I should let everyone at home
know that James
never saw those cue cards or
wore that wig until just now.
He had no idea.
We just surprised him
on the spot.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Finally, a new survey found
that over a quarter of Americans
have been so hangry
that they've actually
eaten out of the garbage.
The most common explanation
they gave,
"For some reason, the trash bags
smell like pumpkin spice."